as parts of the country go back into
lockdown questions are being asked about
why britain's test and trace system
didn't prevent this second surge
and about why it's proving to be so
expensive
sky news can now reveal just how much
the government is paying some of the
private sector consultants is engaged to
help it
we've seen documents detailing the rates
charged by executives from boston
consulting group a leading management
consultant working on the scheme
they showed that the day rate the
chargeable amount each day for senior
bcg consultants
is 7 360 pounds
bcg have applied a covert discount of 10
to 15 percent
but even after this discount these
executives are being paid rates
equivalent
to a 1.5 million pound annual salary
to work on test and trace for those who
have attempted to investigate the link
between government and private sector
consultants
it's deeply worrying i really am shocked
i mean we've known that we've had an
issue with a lot of expenditure or
management consultants
but i didn't think that we'd be spending
that much with
such sub-optimal results
a department of health and social care
spokesperson said to build the largest
diagnostic network in british history
it requires us to work with both public
and private sector partners with the
specialist skills and experience we need
every pound is spent contributing
towards our efforts to keep people safe
as we ramp up testing capacity it's hard
to think of another part of the
government's covid strategy that is as
crucial
and controversial as test and trace and
these documents we've uncovered
underline
that controversy for not only do they
show the scale of the rewards
given out to private sector consultants
they also show that far from scaling it
down
they're planned to be scaled up with
hundreds more consultants taken on
over the course of the next few weeks to
work on the government's new
moonshot testing program the shadow
health secretary vowed to raise the
issue in parliament
these are staggering figures and what
they reveal is that the taxpayer is
paying hand over fist huge amounts to
these private firms
and we're getting a really poor quality
return we can't we've got a testing
system
which fell over and the government are
just throwing money
at private firms who are not delivering
the app will help us
safely live our lives still some argue
that without management consultants the
government's program
would be facing even more trouble this
has been a mammoth challenge
uh for com for government you know if
you look at within
three weeks uh they were able to set up
the booking system
for for test and trace so having to
respond at
speed and at pace and has required
the government to bring in private
sector expertise
the selling point of britain's testing
system budgeted to cost 12 billion
pounds
was that it would help prevent a second
and third wave of the virus
with that ambition not having been met
many will wonder now
whether that money much of it going to
the private sector is money well spent
ed conway sky news